[Music]
the guard is
90 some odd percent i believe
male uh only about
20 of white males voted for bible
they're probably not more than 25
of the people that are there protecting
us who voted for biden the other 75
percent
are in the class that would be uh the
large class of folks
who might want to do something so it
does concern me
he's concerned about the inauguration
and having too many white males in
uniform
democratic congressman steve cut the
security risk to the inauguration as if
anyone who didn't vote for biden
is by definition a threat to our country
joining us now jeremy hunt
west point grad army veteran and yale
law student you can hit from
uh a bunch of different areas but i'm
gonna tap into your service part of your
background
uh jeremy did you worry about serving
with people who voted differently with
you
should we be worried about the national
guard uh
who didn't vote for joe biden
no look you know when i when i served in
the army i had the privilege of serving
for five years on active duty
i served with people who had all
different types of political views
but what binded us together was a common
creed it was the oath that we took
a fidelity to the constitution and look
here's the thing
and if there are some some
insurrectionists or some
some crazy people who plan on doing some
craziness at the inauguration
look you they have no business wearing
the uniform of the united states
military
go home get out that is completely
unacceptable
and if you are a united states
congressman and you think it's
acceptable to sow
such seeds of hatred especially on a day
like today
you too have no business leading this
country if you think that all
conservatives
who serve are somehow a potential
insider threat like we don't need that
in our country
and he too should go home so i'll just
take the uh
i'll take the the other side of it they
say well you know that that woman who
served in the air force from
seemed to have been uh a fan or a member
of q anon
who got shot sadly was an air force
veteran uh one of the
uh the men that broke into the capitol
had a military helmet on
he was an uh an air force officer what
do you say to people go i'm worried now
about the military members
well i'll just say personally it's just
so embarrassing
uh that there were any uh
or even law enforcement officers that
were at all involved in what happened
there
uh i was completely i think i've talked
to other people too that served me
it was completely embarrassing but what
i saw as a response
was people all around people all around
the military coming together saying look
this has no room in our united states
armed forces
that is what the united states military
stands for and that's why i was proud to
serve
and when you saw a officer get hit by a
trump supporter i'm thinking
what speech should they watch donald
trump make that ever was
anti-law enforcement anything but praise
so that's why i find an initial thing
that's impossible to figure out about
that event
you wrote a great column today on fox
news.com about martin luther king and
what it meant to you
growing up and today in a time in which
we're taking down so many statues
why is it important to not uh to
look at martin luther king jr and make
sure we respect what he stood for
well look uh it was a complete honor to
write that column because
dr king's legacy is that he waged war on
hate
and like i grew up in the south i i you
know i remember one day just going to
school and my
car was completely covered in car paint
with the word with the n-word written
all over it
fast forward in a number of years even
now as i as i speak out on my views
my family's been attacked i've been i've
been called an uncle tom i've been
called
words that i can't even say on the air
and look so i know what it's like to be
angry
i know what it's like to want
retribution to want to kind of get back
at some of these people who are
spreading such hate
but dr king taught us there is a
different way
we should have a righteous anger that
should be channeled
in healthy ways and so let's see how we
can weed out the hatred in this country
and get back to what has made our
country
so incredible absolutely uh jeremy hill
well put well written thanks so much for
joining us now back to the books back to
school
thank you brian i appreciate it all
right